Hupe wenn du eine Vasektomie hattest
steht auf dem Anhänger und tatsächlich
alle paar Minuten macht es
und springt den Mann hinterm Steuer zum
Schmunzeln Eska Guarin 45 Jahre alt
Urologe und stolzer Besitzer der wohl
einzigen mobilen vasektomie-klinik
Amerikas einmal im Monat geht er in
seinem Bundesstaat Iowa auf Tour sein
Ziel klar Geld verdienen für ihn aber
noch wichtiger er möchte über das Thema
Verhütung aufklären
[Musik]
Frauen sind nur zwischen der Pubertät
und der Menopause fruchtbar also etwa
bis zum 50 Lebensjahr der Eisprung ist
nur an einem einzigen Tag im Monat da
wäre es doch viel sinnvoller sich auf
den Mann zu konzentrieren der jeden
einzelnen Tag seines lebensfruchtbar ist
ab der Pubertät bis wir sterben ich
glaube wir erleben da gerade so etwas
wie ein Erwachen
um dieses Erwachen weiter zu fördern
fährt der Arzt bewusst abgelegenere Orte
an an denen es weniger Bildung aber auch
weniger Vasektomie Anbieter gibt manche
sehen in Eska guardin eine Provokation
auf Rädern Verhütung in dem der Mann
sterilisiert wird auf keinen Fall sagen
die einen unbedingt sagen besonders Jena
die Frauen keine Hormoneinnahme zur
Verhütung zumuten wollen und mit Sorge
auf die neuen abtreibungsverbote blicken
sein nächster Stopp die Kleinstadt
Waterloo meist baut er seine Klinik auf
zentral gelegenen Parkplätzen auf
Behörden und anliegende Firmen haben
damit selten ein Problem eine
gesetzliche Regelung gibt es für mobiler
vasektomie-kliniken nicht wie man einen
umgebauten Campingwagen
schwankungssicher macht musste der
Urologe erstmal lernen
wir wollen doch nicht dass ich
herumwandler oder
das sind alles Dinge die ich erstmal neu
Bedenken musste als ich den Anhänger
habe bauen lassen
sein boomendes Geschäft steht ihnen
direktem Zusammenhang mit der Diskussion
um Abtreibungen nachdem der Oberste
Gerichtshof vor gut einem Jahr das
bundesweite Recht darauf gekippt hat
verschärfen mehr und mehr US-Staaten die
Regeln auch in Iowa ist das ein großes
Thema so wird der Supreme Court dort
mutmaßlich bis Ende Juni darüber
entscheiden ob der Zugang zu
Schwangerschaftsabbrüchen deutlich
erschwert wird die
abtreibungsbeschränkungen führen dazu
dass die Nachfrage nach vasektomien
stark steigt im letzten Jahr laut der
angio plant parenthootch landesweit um
etwa ein Drittel
[Musik]
ich denke hier passiert etwas sehr
amerikanisches was ich an diesem Land
sehr schätze die Menschen verteidigen
ihre persönlichen Rechte und setzen sich
für sie ein das ist der Grund warum das
Thema bei den letzten Zwischenwahlen das
umstrittenste von allen war denn es
betrifft das grundlegende Recht eines
Individuums selbst zu entscheiden wenn
es um so etwas Wichtiges geht wie ihre
Fruchtbarkeit
auch Andrew und Kristin Carla verfolgen
die Diskussion seit langem und finden
jede Frau sollte selbst entscheiden
können
unabhängig von dieser Debatte möchte der
35-Jährige heute eine Vasektomie
vornehmen lassen nach ihrem ersten Kind
wollten die Carlos ein weiteres sie
bekamen Zwillinge damit war ihre
Familienplanung abgeschlossen
Männer sollten mehr Verantwortung
übernehmen mein Vater hatte auch damals
eine Vasektomie machen lassen meine
Familie hat was das angeht also schon
immer recht progressiv gedacht
und hoffentlich werden das künftig mehr
Männer so sehen
Doktor
die Samenleiter der Eingriff dauert
wenige Minuten währenddessen steigt bei
Christian Carla schon die Vorfreude nach
18 Jahren kann die 36-Jährige endlich
die Pille absetzen sie hatte ihrem
Körper immer wieder Probleme bereitet
es wird toll sein mein Körper endlich
wieder selbst in der Hand zu haben das
wird wunderbar und ich glaube mein Mann
freut sich mit mir darüber
im Halbstunden-Takt trudeln die
Patienten in der mobilen Klinik ein
599 Dollar berechnet Doktor guardin für
den Eingriff etwa die Hälfte der
bundesweiten Durchschnittskosten für
eine Vasektomie das die Regeln für
Abtreibungen vielerorts strenger werden
hat ashleyn und Jacob Barbers
Entscheidung heute herzukommen
maßgeblich beeinflusst
die landesweite abtreibungsdiskussion
hat meinen Blick auf die Dinge verändert
gerade nachdem das bundesweiter
Abtreibungsrecht aufgehoben wurde das
hat uns zu denken gegeben vorher war das
für uns nie wirklich ein großes Thema
aber jetzt dachten wir auf einmal oh
mein Gott das könnte für uns echt ein
Problem werden also ja das hat unsere
Entscheidung stark beeinflusst
Freunde nennen sein Bus liebevoll den
Nussknacker bei allem Humor davon hält
der Arzt eher wenig
die Bezeichnung hört sich putzig an aber
sie ist irreführend denn das ist nicht
was wir machen wir knacken gar nichts
stattdessen nenne ich ihn lieber den
mythosknacker mit der mobilen
vasektomie-klinik können wir auch mit
manchem Vorurteil zu vasektomien
aufräumen
[Musik]
und so führen unter anderem die strenger
werdenden abtreibungsregeln dazu dass
viele in den USA die Rolle von Mann und
Frau beim Thema Verhütung überdenken was
manch einer als gegen die Natur oder
Angriffe auf die Männlichkeit empfindet
scheint für immer mehr Männer ganz
normal zu sein